[Music]
gravity falls is one of the best
cartoons ever but have you ever explored
the mysteries behind it we bet you
didn't know the dark secret grunkle Stan
is actually hiding give this video a
thumbs up and hit that subscribe button
then never miss another video again now
let's check out 10 dark secrets and
gravity falls
censorship let's start with the one
secret no one really talks about Disney
censorship happens in every single show
we all know gravity falls features some
of the darkest humor that doesn't really
translate well in many other countries
but it looks like that censored lines
and altered scenes happen quite
frequently in Southeast Asia for example
Stan Pines Fez was even completely
removed from the show strange right
Southeast Asia also censored all words
that might be considered swearing even
if that's not the case by the US
standards
do you remember Fords but I'm a freak
line in a tale of two Stan's it got
shortened to just but I am of course
this type of censorship occurs due to
the culture of the country however you
have to admit that gravity falls is very
different without the specific sayings
scenes and even Stan's FETs this pretty
much means that southeast asia latin
america and several other countries
watched a completely different show of
course many countries have also censored
the final scene with sheriff blubs and
deputy Durland which is pretty
heartbreaking considered how many fans
suspected and wanted these two to end up
being together but no matter how
progressive gravity falls might be for a
cartoon scene some words that aren't in
line with other cultures will get
totally censored Illuminati this isn't
really a dark secret but we all know
that gravity falls has always been
connected with Illuminati and this dark
secret is really just light hearted but
we had to throw it in there in the
modern world the word Illuminati means
an organization that is known to control
world's affairs it's usually represented
by a triangle and of course we all know
gravity falls features the exact same
triangle also known as bill cipher
several fan theories involve people
discussing whether or not gravity falls
is actually connected with Illuminati
make sure to give us your thoughts in
the comments below
here's another secret we bet you didn't
know Alex Hirsch actually talks with the
official Illuminati organization on
Twitter after it was said that the
organization thanks him for creating
gravity falls
Alex
jokingly replied that he doesn't really
care about their gratitude and that he
wants an actual seat at the Illuminati
table the organization says they'll
gladly accept him because they noticed
the little shoutouts this might all
sound like a huge joke but we have a
feeling there are conspiracy theorists
out there that will definitely consider
this one of the show's darkest secrets
what do you think is Alex Hirsch really
a member of actual Illuminati stay tuned
on another secret Alex accidentally
tweeted to his followers a lost episode
but first let's talk about how Alex
loves to joke around with his fans on
Twitter if you've been a fan of the show
for a long time you know what we mean in
2017 Alex tweeted a secret he seemed to
have been hiding for the longest time he
stated that he always wanted to do an
episode where grunkle Stan started his
own religion called Stan ontology he
drew a picture with grunkle Stan saying
that alien ghosts live in your bones and
asking for a tax break
this was a clear dig at the
controversial religion of Scientology
and it looked like the legal department
didn't want this to happen but
Scientology wasn't the only religion
Alex was interested in he also said that
Stan's holy book would be a 300 page
manual on bribery and it would be called
the Bible sounds familiar we can
definitely see why the legal department
would want to object to this story in
order to save a few lawsuits on the
other hand we'd love to see who would
get on board with Stan ontology we have
a few characters in mind this was
definitely one of the most recent
secrets that would have never been known
if it wasn't for Alex Hirsch is Twitter
we really want to see this lost episode
love God speaking of censored moments
one of the gravity falls scenes never
made it on air and it wasn't just in
international countries it seems like
the production team had something
against the scene and to be completely
honest we're totally shocked
considering how progressive this show
actually is when it comes to
controversial subjects we all saw the
love God episode but did you know that
the editors change for the meaning of a
particular scene it caused a huge
controversy within the LGBT community
the animator of the show posted what
she's been working on on tumblr but many
fans noticed that her drawings changed
in the final version do you remember
what the Cupid's pendant looked like it
was the symbols representing males and
females but in the original drawing the
cupid was supposed to wear the symbol of
the LGBTQ community they also changed
the gender of the person the old woman
was suppose
to be matched with according to original
images it was supposed to be an old
woman since gravity falls is an
extremely progressive show we actually
don't think people would mind but then
again it seemed that the editors had a
different opinion was Disney right for
altering these scenes or should they
have kept it in we all know they would
have been censored in other countries
anyways not canceled we're still not
over the fact that the show ended but
did you know that gravity falls wasn't
actually canceled it's a common
misconception among the viewers but the
actual explanation is even weirder
despite the popularity of the show Alex
Hirsch didn't intend the show to go past
two seasons he said that there are so
many shows that go on endlessly until
they lose their original spark or
mysteries that are canceled before they
ever get a chance to pay off but the
situation seems a bit weird since Disney
released a statement saying they were
disappointed in hearing the show was
finished and even Alex hinted that we
might see dipper Maybelle and Stan again
do you believe that Alex's decision to
finish the show was totally his own or
was he influenced by Disney in any way
if he was so ready to close this chapter
why did he say that we'd see the
characters in the future the long hiatus
between the two seasons is also rumored
to have an influence on the cancellation
of this show we want answers and we want
them now as of January 2018
Alex's Twitter bio states that he's
currently cooking up new mischief but
there hasn't been any kind of updates at
all for a long time come on alex hirsch
what's happening are we getting a
completely new show or will we see
dipper mabel and Stan's somewhere else
Alex hurts so let's talk more about Alex
who's definitely not the typical Disney
creator along with having a fantastic
sense of humor he also has an amazingly
creative mind that mother seems to slow
down it seems like the creator of the
show really started to miss gravity
falls in 2017 because he jokingly
tweeted that if nobody liked her
retweeted his tweet he'd make new
episodes of course people liked and
retweeted it but if they didn't we'd
possibly have new episodes which makes
even less sense considering Alex was
officially done with the show what's the
truth Alex he also hinted that possible
season 3 or even a special episode
before and said that it's hard to
abandon such personality rich characters
we just don't understand why he would
release a statement saying he's totally
done with the show why not just go on
another long hiatus and come back with
new ideas instead
we're telling you alex has a dark secret
and he really doesn't want to reveal
everything but we seem to be getting a
lot of interesting hints who's holding
him back is it Disney or is it all just
a ploy to keep the fans interested and
engaged until something new comes along
we have a feeling the truth will come
out very soon disturbing scenes you
probably know that gravity falls has a
lot of pretty disturbing scenes that can
easily give you nightmares and pretty
much make you want to look away at some
point many fans question how is this
still a children's show
considering season 2 was significantly
darker than the first one of the most
nightmarish scenes includes the scary
animals from Northwest mystery mansion
which many fans crown is the scariest
episode ever even for adults
so how come Disney censors lgbtq scenes
but leaves gruesome moments that might
significantly scare their younger
viewers Disney never seemed to have
addressed this issue it's surprising
that parents seem to give good reviews
to the show but if you watched our other
videos you know parents heavily
criticized Disney shows like victorious
for their inappropriate scenes some of
the most gruesome gravity fall scenes
always involve some form of blood but
it's also been noted that some of the
scariest moments from the show also
involve episodes like the legend of the
gobblewonker and weirdmageddon part 1
we're kind of shocked that Disney didn't
pull a plug on this one but stopped a
lot of lighter scenes from many other
shows who knows maybe Alex Hirsch really
is a part of the Illuminati and gets
special rights when it comes to creating
scenes that can definitely leave you
with a couple of nightmares be intro ok
this one isn't a dark secret but it's
definitely an interesting hidden message
have you ever studied the gravity falls
intro scene it comes with a lot of
hidden secrets no one ever addressed did
you notice that apart from Bigfoot's
foot Bigfoot also makes an appearance in
the intro you can barely see him but you
should be able to find him if you stop
the frame at the right time but let's
focus on the mystical page where there
are definitely a lot of things happening
of course there's the little shout-out
to Illuminati but there are also several
other messages that are hidden away from
ordinary eyes each symbol around bill
cipher represents one of the gravity
falls characters but it also includes
the hand symbol which represents the
journal on the far right you can also
see the famous kono michi code that
up to 99 lives to any player there are
many more symbols on that page that were
never really resolved we can clearly see
binary numbers and other cryptic
information that probably hold a lot
more secrets than we'll ever know can
you decode every single message on the
page it also tells us that Stan's not
what he seems but we'll talk more about
that in just a little bit the
time-travelling gravity falls is known
for its running gas which is exactly why
the show is so amazing some of them end
up being explained and play a
significant part in the story while
others are kept a mystery forever the
time travelers Pig episode introduced us
to blendin blandin the time traveller
but you probably missed how many times
he appeared before that episode you can
even spot him in the legend of the
gobble Walker and several other scenes
you probably never noticed he's easy to
miss but he's always there it seems like
no one ever explained the significance
of this time traveler and why he got to
appear in so many moments whether this
is just a running gag you never even
discover or a deeper meaning we'll never
know the true story behind the time
traveler but it definitely got us
intrigued all we want to know is how
severe dipper and Mabel's paradox holes
were considering he's there and a lot of
early scenes and exactly what they did
to mess with the paradox Disney we have
questions and we definitely want some
answers seriously what's the deal with
the time traveler and how different
would everything turn out if he never
fixed what he had to fix it's definitely
one of our favorite unexplainable
moments but nothing beats our very last
secret Stan's dark secret even the intro
says that Stan's not what he seems and
if you've seen every episode of gravity
falls you know he's been also considered
as leading a double life but there's
something else that's pretty dark about
grunkle Stan many fans seem to believe
that he seems to be totally controlled
by bill cipher in almost every episode
Stan goes outside during the night and
at some point he even questions why he's
out there in the first place
he often behaves so weirdly it really
feels like he's being controlled by
someone else or in this case something
else fans have also highlighted the fact
that both bill cipher and Stan talked
about buying gold because the apocalypse
is coming a fan believes that bill
ciphers ability to control a person
depends on that person's desire in this
case it's money which is all Stan talks
about some fans also believe Stan knows
a lot more than he seems to share did
you ever notice there's an apocalypse
let's bunker behind Stan's vending
machine he definitely seems to know that
an apocalypse will be coming we all know
Stan's crazy and there are definitely a
lot more mysteries to him that were
never properly explained but this secret
is the one the fans want to know about
the most
as of January 2018 Stan's dark secret
was never addressed by any Disney
official and that's it for our video for
more videos like this one check out 10
gravity falls episodes that weren't for
kids see you next time
[Music]